you know how much longer do you want to
do this job
well i would think four or five more
years because now we're going after
just uh fugitives or
people wanted that rape children or beat
up wives
or do something very violent because the
days of the drug addict going to jail
and the burglar and all that are over
and so many times i booked someone in
jail and as i walk out
now they're holding the door for me
right
so i'm going after the worst there is
because i don't
they're not getting out and it's you
know it's the last quarter of my game
and you know i want to take out the the
worst they've got
so here we come meanwhile you become a
movie star
thank you i just saw it today did you
really yeah oh
even in the daylight the woods can be
confusing ain't nothing in the woods you
can't kill that boat
if i don't find them i'm gonna find out
what happened
so uh how how'd i do being myself
that's what i was gonna say you played
yourself how is that playing yourself
stop it come on well it's easy because
you're playing yourself it's when you've
got to get in
state and you know you're playing some
vampires get away from me
because you're in state ready to go
right but i still had to get in state
whether i was playing
myself or not you know people would try
to talk to me during breaks i go
excuse me i'm not rude just please go on
and i was like you know
it's it's uh fun i love and they give
you what to say
and this movie also is kind of it has
a special theme that is near and dear to
your heart
correct because it's a husband losing
his wife
yes so what was that like for you
playing in a movie where
the husband loses his wife well i've
always seen
actors and or heard them say the part i
played was
i really went through that in my life so
when you're
in there you have to be who they want
you to be
if you've been through the scenes
actually in your life
you're just bringing it back up so
it wasn't hard for me i didn't have to
pretend and i didn't have to
you know store storylines i just
let it out right yeah and i think you
know and it's a christian-based
movie talks a lot about god the the
guys you know end up going hunting the
girl gets sick and then passes away
and the guy's like you know i can't say
no more but uh it was right up my alley
at that time
would your boys ever do anything with
him would they ever go out and bounce
off they want to
so yeah yeah really bad they want to
well leland we're should i say this now
come on so we're opening a new app
called dog unleashed
it took us three days to catch people
okay and let's say
there are four days let's go higher four
days 10 hours a day camera footage
you know yeah you get 42 minutes right
right right you're like where is that
scene oh dawg we didn't have enough room
to put that scene
but wait a minute i look like superman
coming through there man
sorry dog at the capture blah blah now
we're gonna have a show
and it's already today it launched where
we're gonna show the whole thing
dog unleashed so the first few shows
uh leland my son is going to train greg
her son
and there the two families are going to
get together and we are
literally we've got fbi behind we got
them all
we're going after the worst of the worst
when did you become a tick tock star
explain the whole talk evolution
lamborghini
so my little granddaughter baby lisa's
daughter
was doing tick tock right and so i come
up behind her and
chaka hey wave the dogs follow me
and hundreds of times crazy
it's crazy so she was born on television
madeline right so always i say maddie
where are you born
on tv and what are you gonna do when you
grew up be on tv
and so to her she's adorable she got all
those hits and she's like
yeah she's normal you know who would
have known
a year ago you're going to meet this
girl and then you're going to be under
quarantine
and you can't go nowhere but with this
girl and you're going to go through
i mean you talk about getting to know
each other quick
god is moving fast everywhere
so that you know the quarantine and you
can't go
and da da da just got us closer and go
you know you say wow every day i'm
loving you more and what the heck is
going on here
that's what i do what is happening here
not what we expected but it turned into
something wonderful and amazing
you